(bright music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable.
Yet, filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly, we hand down knowledge,
we empathize and deceive.
We shape the future
from our shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(techy music)
(upbeat music)
- Alright, so to address this question,
the impact of tool use and technology
on the evolution of the human mind,
I wanna begin by addressing this question.
How can we account for our species
immense ecological dominance
and our stunning technological prowess?
Now when people approach this question,
they come to it with certain intuitions.
Intuitions that we're smart,
we're good at building causal
models of how the world works,
we're good at individually figuring out,
and this must be the
secret of our success.
But it turns out that
that's not the best story,
and that we're actually not that good
at figuring things out.
What I'm gonna try to convince you today,
is that in fact there's another
way of approaching this,
and there's a different explanation
for the secret of our success.
Okay, so I'm gonna just begin
with a little bit of data.
This comes from a battery
of cognitive tests
administered to three different species,
so two and 1/2 year old humans,
chimpanzees, and orangutans,
and this research is
done by Esther Herrmann
and Mike Tomasello at
the Max Planck Institute
for Evolutionary Anthropology.
18 different cognitive tests broken down
into three different areas.
Space, subset of tests on space,
quantities, causality,
and social learning.
And what you can see from
this figure here is that...
The humans do about as well as the chimps,
they get about 70% right on the space,
the chimps actually do slightly better
than the humans on quantity.
So that's within the margin of error,
but the chimps do a little bit better.
And same thing on causality,
the chimps do marginally better.
Now, if you dig into the causality test
and look specifically at the tests
that try to measure
differences in tool using,
the chimps actually do
much better on tool using
than the two and 1/2 year old children.
Now I think the real telling point here
is that if I were to give these,
this battery of cognitive
tests to you guys,
you would blow the roof off the test,
and you'd do much better than the apes.
So between two and going
up well into the 20s,
we get better and better at these kinda,
solving these cognitive problems.
So something is happening
during that time.
Meanwhile, if we look at the chimpanzees,
there's no change over
the course of their lives,
in fact, sometimes the young chimpanzees,
the five year old chimpanzees,
are better at the tasks
than the older chimpanzees.
So that's a hint to what
must be going on there.
There's nothing special about
these particular measures.
I could show you data on working memory,
whereas chimps and humans
engaging in strategic thinking,
and you would see that there's no
particular human advantage in this.
Another way of getting at this
would be to think about taking this room
of very smart people
and parachuting you into the Ituri forest,
or into the Amazon Basin,
and having you try to survive.
(laughter)
You would no doubt struggle,
you couldn't start fire,
you couldn't make tools.
If it was a game of survivor,
you would probably lose
to Dorothy's capuchins.
(laughter)
So we're clearly missing something.
Humans rely on this large
body of cultural inheritance.
So it's not our innate intelligence,
or our problem solving abilities,
or our ability to build
causal models on the fly,
but something else.
So where do our fancy tools
and technologies come from?
I'm gonna make the case
that it comes from our collective brain.
And particularly our
collective brain is anchored
in our cultural natures
and social natures.
These are two separate things.
Our cultural natures is our
ability to learn from others,
to look out into the minds and behaviors
of others in our social milieu,
and filter out and learn ideas,
beliefs, values, practices
from other members of our group.
The social part is that
for various reasons,
we're able to live in large groups,
and the larger the group, the better.
The more we're able to generate
ideas, beliefs, and values
that are adapted to our environments,
more sophisticated technologies.
Alright, now to get at this question
from an evolutionary perspective.
This approach was actuality
Marcus Feldman lead us off today
in 1976 he wrote a paper with
Luca Luigi Cavalli-Sforza,
in which they made the first effort
to take the logic of natural selection
of genetic evolution and to think about
how it might've shaped our
psychology for cultural learning.
Our abilities to adaptively
extract ideas, beliefs,
and values from other
members of our social group.
Others like Boyden
Richardson went to build on,
build a large research
program on that process.
And since then, there's been
a great deal of research,
much of it with young children,
showing that from even before age one,
we keenly attend to who we learn from,
so we learn from certain individuals,
or particular about what we learn from
how we integrate information
across individuals,
and when we choose to use social learning
over our own intuitions
or our own experience.
Together, when you put all this together
in large groups over many generations,
it produces what I call
cultural adaptations,
and this includes the fancy
tools and technologies
that we're so impressive
for in the natural world.
Now this process can, and often does,
operate outside of conscious awareness.
One of my favorite things
to do is to regale people
with many, many examples
of all the ways in which
cultural evolution
builds adaptive behavior
in ways that are unconscious
and unseen behind the scenes.
I'll just give you one example today.
It's something you're already
familiar with, spices.
So people use spices in different ways,
different cultures have
different spicing traditions,
some places use many more spices
in their recipes than other places.
But once you realize that
spices are an adaptation
to the problem of food born pathogens,
you can predict a whole
bunch of things about
the kinds of plants
for which we'll harvest
their chemical properties
and put them in our foods,
which societies will tend
to use a lot of spices,
which spices they'll use,
and how they'll recombine
spices in syngenetic ways
that make it more powerful
and more anti-microbial.
And you can predict which kinds of foods.
And this can all happen
outside of conscious awareness,
many of you probably didn't
know that spicing was
protecting against food born pathogens,
and in some cases, it's
even possible to show that
if people understood,
they might be less likely
to do the behavior, and
it would be maladaptive.
So understanding is a bad thing.
(laughter)
In some cases.
When you begin to build models
and think about how humans learn,
so we take what we know
about human learning,
and we allow humans to learn in groups
and are connected in different ways,
one of the robust
findings from what is now
a decent body of literature,
is that larger and more
innerconnected populations
evolve technologies and tools
and other aspects of culture
more quickly and adapting
to their environment,
and their ability to hold and preserve
large bodies of different tools
and technologies is bigger,
is more, they can hold
more in larger populations.
Even more interesting, and
something that you can use
to solve various puzzles
throughout human history
and around the world
is that a sudden reduction
in the size of a population
will cause populations
to ebb away technology,
to lose things over time.
Now, one piece of evidence
that I like for this
is research done by Michelle
Kline and Robert Boyd,
and what these anthropologists did,
is they went back to the ethnography
from societies all over Polynesia,
and they coded marine foraging technology.
And they counted the number of tools
these different islands
around the Pacific had,
and they also assessed the complexity.
And you can see here,
this is an example of how
very simple method
developed by Wendell Oswalt,
in which you just count
the parts in the tool,
and you can get a number of
techno-units for that tool.
Show you the results here, quickly.
In this plot here on this side,
you can see this is the population size,
it's a log scale.
These dots are the different islands,
and this is the number of tools.
So larger islands had more different kinds
of tools for marine foraging.
And this is the mean
number of techno-units,
so not only did larger
islands have more total tools,
those tools were on average more complex,
they had more parts.
You can see that they also
differentiated by contact,
so in addition to the population size,
they got a measure of how
connected the islands were.
And islands that had more contact
with other islands in the Pacific,
they're above the line,
which means that, they have
an extra boost over and above
their population size from
the interconnectedness,
from being a little
bit more interconnected
with other populations.
One thing that's interesting
from the point of view
of looking back at the
paleo-anthropological record,
is it's not an uncommon
practice to try to infer things
about the cognition of ancient creatures
based on the kinda tools they make.
But if you were to use
that same approach here,
you would deduce that the
folks who lived in Hawaii,
traditionally, were much smarter
and more mentally sophisticated
than the folks who lived in a small island
off the coast of New Guinea.
The lesson here is that it's really
the collective brain
that's doing the work,
not the individual smarts
of the people in the brain.
Incidentally, this was part
of the Austronesian expansion,
so it's relatively recent.
We can be confident there aren't
genetic differences there.
Okay.
Alright, now I don't want you to think
that this is just interesting
for thinking about
ancient Polynesian societies.
So I put in this plot, which is US cities
and the number of innovations they produce
based on patent data.
So the larger the US city, over 10,000,
the more patents they produce.
That's not too interesting in that,
we would expect larger
cities to have more people
to produce more patents.
But this is a super linear relationship.
Which means controlling for things like
education and occupation,
the same person put into a larger city
is more likely to produce
patents and innovations.
So the people get more
innovative in larger cities,
there's a number of data sets
showing the same relationship.
Okay, now those are all
interesting correlations,
but we can't be too confident
there's actually a causal relationship.
So what researchers have done
is to go to the laboratory
and try to create micro-societies,
which allow us to get some insights.
The typical micro-society that's been used
by a number of different researchers,
is to take a bunch of,
say 100 undergraduates,
and create generations.
So each individual gets a
task that they have to solve,
they do their best on the task,
my tradition likes to pay
people for right answers,
and then they transmit the
information in some way
down to another generation
of undergraduates,
you know, laboratory generations.
Who then takes that
information, does their best,
and passes it down.
So we're gonna run this
for 10 generations.
Now the key thing in this
setup is that in this,
the individual condition,
you can only learn from one teacher.
So not much interconnectedness.
In this condition, you could learn
from any one of the five
in the prior generations,
so you could potentially recombine ideas
from different individuals.
They had to replicate this image
with a notoriously user
unfriendly image editing program,
and they had a time limit.
As I mentioned, they're
paid for their performance,
but they're also incentivized
for their student's performance.
So they get more money if
they send good instructions,
which then after the task,
they can write up to two pages,
which goes down to the next generation.
It allows us to analyze the
kinds of things people said.
In the next generation,
everybody after generation one,
they get the model's product,
which they can compare to
the target image, this image,
and they get the write-up,
and then they have a go
at the task themselves.
This is the results, so 10 generations.
You can see here in generation one,
they actually had a pretty good group
of the single learning tradition group.
But in the more interconnected group,
they didn't have such a lucky first group.
But here, accumulative cultural
evolutionary process kicked in,
where they could take from
the previous generation,
they could add to it,
any lucky insights were brought together,
and then passed down so that by the end,
the 10th generation is twice as skilled
as the 10th generation
in the other treatment.
Not only that, if you break down
and look at the data individually,
the worst person in the
interconnected population,
so the population that
could learn from others,
is better than the best person
in the single population,
where you just have one-to-one learning.
So it makes a big difference in how
apparently smart people look.
It looks like they can
just do things better.
Alright.
I wanna get back to the question
I began at the beginning
when I introduced the apes and the humans.
This was the idea that,
so something from going
from a two and 1/2 year
old when your cognition
is not that much better than a chimpanzee,
'til you're 20-something,
when you can blow the roof off the test,
what happens there?
And part of what's going on here,
is a download of prebuilt solutions
that have accumulated in our
inherited body of knowhow
over many generations.
So simple things like springs, and screws,
and levers, and pulleys,
are hard to invent for the first time.
But once you grow up in an environment
that has springs, and screws,
and levers, and pulleys,
they're easy to figure out and
then reapply to new contexts.
One example that I like is the wheel.
It seems relatively simple.
You see Gary Larson cartoons
with ancient human ancestors
experimenting with wheels, but actually,
the wheel arrives relatively
late in human history,
about 6,000 years ago.
It appears on carts and then pottery.
Eventually it's used to transfer
power, but only in Eurasia.
It doesn't appear in the North America,
South America, Oceania, Australia.
So they don't invent wheels.
Sometimes people have pointed to
certain kinds of animals being present,
but the dog's everywhere,
and you can see the Belgians here
are using this dog to pull their cart.
So there's at least some kind
of animals that can pull.
And then once you have wheels,
you can do all kinds of things with them.
Elastically stored energy
used to make a bow and arrow,
never invented in Australia.
You don't see anything with
elastically stored energy.
Fletching is not invented in New Guinea,
although, New Guinea folks
do have bows and arrows.
We heard from Raphael
about the counting systems.
So lots of societies like
Machiguenga, who I worked with,
count one, two, three, many.
This group counts to 27,
you can see Raphael and I
read the same literature.
(chuckling)
You can find everything in between,
so you can find groups
that count to 11, 13, 36,
some groups figure out how to cycle.
But you guys have all been bequeathed
a counting system that allows
you to count without bound.
Another example is the number zero.
So the number zero, as a placeholder,
has only been invented
twice in human history.
Once by the Mayans and
the second time in India.
It diffuses to Europe
through Islamic societies.
My favorite example is the abacus.
So you can track the
evolution of the abacus
from babylonian counting boards,
and you can see how the
abacus is evolving culturally,
the tech use of how we use
space and how we clump things,
in order to exploit aspects
of our evolved cognition.
But then, what's amazing to me,
is that children can train on the abacus,
the physical device, and then
with sufficient training,
they can put the abacus aside.
And then you can give them incredibly
complex calculation problems,
where they're adding up large
numbers, 10 or 15 of them,
and they do it, you can
see their fingers moving,
and they're not touching
anything physical,
and they seem to be looking up in the air,
and then suddenly they
come out with the answer.
They have races between the mental abacus
and the calculator.
So this is a whole new cognitive ability,
that's kinda bootstrapped up
from this physical apparatus,
which evolved culturally to
fit aspects of our minds.
So this gives us a different picture
of how humans have evolved.
So culture-driven genetic evolution.
Sometime in our species'
evolutionary history,
I think it happened before
bout two million years ago,
we became a species with
accumulative cultural evolution.
What we passed down from one generation
was built upon by the next generation.
How this happened, if you wanna know that,
you'll have to read my book,
The Secret of Our Success.
I actually favor a kind
of social explanation,
so if we became more social
and had larger groups,
that could push a group of
primates across this threshold,
what I call the rubicon,
and this lead to ongoing
cultural evolution.
Now of course, genetic
evolution doesn't stop,
it hasn't stopped now.
So we have two parallel
inheritance systems,
and these inheritance
systems have been interacting
over millions of years, potentially,
or at least hundreds of thousands.
So you can produce
things like stone tools,
like Dietrich told us about,
that allow you to process food
and reduce the selection
pressure on your teeth,
and your chewing apparatus.
It can produce things
like fire and cooking,
which allows us to externalize
our digestive system,
and shrink our colons,
shrink our stomachs.
It supplies energy to allow
us to have larger brains,
gives us extra dexterity in
our hands to use those tools,
and in particular, in this world,
our brains are being selected
for their ability to
acquire, organize, store,
and retransmit cultural information.
We're cultural learners,
that's because the more
our brains get better at
doing this culture thing,
the more accumulative cultural
evolution is gonna create
things that we need to learn.
So now the game is that
all the valuable stuff
I need to know is in the
minds of the prior generation,
and if I can learn something from him,
and something from him,
and something from her,
then I can recombine them
and have an even better
cultural repertoire.
So things like throwing and
finding tubers underground,
water containers can allow us to engage in
long distance running,
and persistent hunting,
this is gonna create a
pressure for even larger brains
to learn all those tools and technologies.
Clothings and adhesives,
eventually projectiles,
and this can explain why we have,
what we seem to have a
specialized cognition
for learning about artifacts,
and we regard and learn about
those in a different way,
than we learn about things
in the biological world,
so plants and animals.
And in particular, it helps explain
why we're willing to put faith
in the wisdom of prior generations.
Developmental psychologists
call this over-imitation,
why we copy all the steps,
but it also explains
why we might be willing
to believe in invisible beings
or other magical powers.
There's a lot of wisdom in the tradition,
and we can't always tell what
the useful information is
from the not-so-useful information.
So the key to understanding humans
is to recognize this long term
period of dual inheritance.
And that's it.
(applause)
(bright music)